Hi, I'm Joe list. Mark Norman here. And we're here at Fordham university.
We're going to take a spin around the museum with our curator, Jennifer.
Yeah, she's good. Very lovely. That's the kind of guy you got a fist bump.
So welcome to the Fordham museum. Greek Etruscan and Roman art. I trust now.
So that's when you ride horses, right? Yes. Trust,
convince. Wow. Trust grant.
That's a question. Ah, no question me.
Let me start over in the corner.
Here.
This is the Harpo Marx trophy. I was thinking Susan Boyle, but yeah,
both work. Yeah. Maybe one, one of the nose is bleeding. Susan boy.
It was a Coke habit. Yeah.
That's actually Medusa. She was supposedly so ugly that when men looked at her,
they turned to stone.
Oh, well wouldn't it be a good thing? Yeah. No.
What are they keeping these usually.
Usually these are, these were just basically funerary.
So nothing was kept in these. Yeah. These ones were directly to the tune.
Oh, I'm at my grandfather's funeral. We were all drinking pretty heavily.
Are you Irish? Yeah.
I turned to stone. It's pretty small.
Actually. Maybe did contain something. Um, grain, grain of some sort.
These were probably likely, um, or at least one of their potential uses.
Whereas whereas kitchen storage vessels.
They just hit us with the number. We came all this way. 300, 400 bucks.
You want to buy one of these things? Yeah. I want to get this a swap meet.
I got that. I got one 80 on me. So look great.
And what do you guys share an apartment.
Timeshare?
What we have in this case are two examples of sinner. Well,
a sinner I earned here and an ossuary ashes. Bones. Oh,
Whoa. Conceptually really cool. Isn't it?
Ashes and bones. A great morning team. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
She's in bones.
What do you make of this little guy on top and the front of him?
What do you think of him? What do you think he is?
Oh yeah. He looks like a Pee-wee's play.
Play house. What about you? What do you think he is in a weather?
Is this a Villanovan geometric impasto circuit. Ninth century. By any chance?
That's extraordinary. I know quite a bit.
He's either an ancestor figure,
which is sort of like the guardian of the house or he is an aperture paying
finger. Do you know what that means? Do you know what that means?
You know what that means? Active.
Do you know what it means for tech? Yeah.
It's a Dominican. Yeah. I think it's acrobatic.
All of these things. You were, you're all drawing the right connection. No,
it actually means to ward off evil.
Uh, it's big. The police are applicant Dre. Wow.
It's like, this is beautiful. I like it in a detail.
What do you think of that detail? It's nice. I got some letters there.
Maximus shorter. I think they could have better details. Like,
like a flame shooting out the side, like a Corvette. Yes.
That kind of detail. Yeah. Yeah. What goes in here? Is this a moving?
I've still got a decal decal. It's not a detail.
A decal decals where I get my drugs decal on 38th
sarcophagus. It means coffin. So can I go to a funeral and go, Hey, a couple.
The good looking sarky yeah.
You could. You could do that. Sarcophagus actually means flesh eating.
Whoa.
Well in a metaphorical type bag.
There, I got a bunny in here. Good bit off
my pants off for this one then. Yeah. Oh boy. Yeah. I got some bacteria,
whole Mesopotamia.
This inscription. Thank you very much. I'm having a hard time today.
You really are by leaps and bounds. Uh,
this inscription tells us,
we hear that he was the father who had the same name as the child.
Livia is probably Maximus was member of the 12th urban cohort,
which is essentially a police precinct. There's a black kid. One of the,
no, he wasn't killed by the police. He was,
he was a member of the police force.
Uh, Irish. Got it. It's a good place to come back to call this an antique
antiques, like a lamp. This is a artifact.
Okay. Antigua. No Aruba. Jamaica. Ooh.
I'd take it to Bermuda.
[inaudible] [inaudible] crustaceans American pickers over this.
What guy? Wouldn't love this for his man cave.
So those two are gay, right? Totally. A couple of guys
pick up toys. Antiques. We drove here and I didn't want to say it.
I do love antiques. These are little marijuana pieces.
Lamps, duck, coals. They are lamps.
Robin. One of those. This is like a mouth harp.
I don't know if you know that bring Well,
I'll see you next week. Thank God. It's not Saturday.
The Sabbath.
Had to say it.
Yeah. Even those guys are outraged.
I got swords down here. Swords. How did I miss the swords spearheads?
Spearpoints sweat.
Really? Isn't my material. I'm just my bag.
Wow. These are great. Oh, look at this tiny little thing.
I have heard that before.
He's pretty great.
I'm finished all comes back to porn and gay for you guys. Doesn't it?
Oh, we love gear. So we met this. This is what we're looking at now.
Uh, yes it is. Yeah. This is excellent observation. We are looking at it.
You know what we're looking? Yeah. What do you make of it? What is it?
This is a motive head of a young man.
I feel is votive to me. It's that kid.
A vote of youth of a capita of the lotto,
which is the type of the type of vote of it.
It feels like a Starbucks beverage. Kevin is a lotto
is a votive speaking of flat and wide question, a real question.
I've already lost interest in
something you offer in a sanctuary is your religious practice.
Got it.
You offer something to the gods and hopefully you get something back,
a little quid pro quo. So to speak.
It sounds a little lambs like silence.
Yes. The Oscars. Yes. Picture director, actor, actress,
screenplay.
The person who published these in our catalog suggested that perhaps they were
part of a, uh, a sarcophagus relief decoration to was on top of it.
Coffin. Yes. But we don't know.
They need to coffin coffin. Take your head and coffin.
Yeah. I've heard of that.
Yeah. Check it out.
Yeah.
This thing is really unbelievable here. This big giant.
Oh, it's a penis I think.
But anatomically.
It looks like an arm. Yeah, kinda. Yeah.
It's a little, uh, fishy.
Animals.
That can be a little bit situation too.
Oh, sorry. The Mollen kicked in.
I can tell that hurts so much.
Oh God.
Uh, yes. Ram headed drinking cup here.
I want you to put your grill right up to there. Yeah. Yeah. That's the one.
And I want you to see that now.
That's what you would see once he finished drinking his wine,
he would turn into a goat head.
Oh yeah. So even back then they had.
Drinking games.
No. Was campus rape a problem back then because it seems to be quite an epidemic
right now. I think it was just rape. Ah, no campus. Yeah.
That they've raped everywhere. Drinking games are fun.
I didn't know that the Romans admit of it being more of a Greek thing.
[inaudible] yes. Hey, they invented it.
Well,
I've been Joe list and I'm Mark norm and we are a lot smarter than we were at
the beginning of the day. You got that right? I was a real idiot. Sure.
Where I didn't want to tell you that one stung.